foreign
Chris is with us Chris is in Fort Worth
Texas hi Chris how are you
hey Rachel and Dave I also watched
borrowed future and that shook me to my
core I think everybody should see it
thank you my question is about you're
welcome my question is about uh the
investment strategy and the four kinds
of good growth stock mutual funds
International is The Fourth Kind that
spreads our risk Beyond American soil uh
it appears to have a lower rate of
returns no it's worse than that it sucks
yeah so why why is it worth uh
diversifying into are we sacrificing
return
why do we do that you know I actually
just asked the same question about
um
oh probably about 24 months ago because
uh you know what we teach are
time-honored principles
like get out of debt and the borrower's
slave to the lender in the Bible and so
we're not going to change on those
things okay we're not going to suddenly
go oh there's a certain kind of you need
to go do this step now we're not going
to do that okay but you know the fort
mutual fund types are something I
dreamed up with other people the guy
that started the show with me was an
investment broker and we dreamed that up
and ran models on it and stuff uh 30
years ago and so it's not a sacred cow
and so I got to looking at it and I'm
looking at my own returns and I'm think
asking the same question you're asking
because this thing I mean it doesn't
just mildly underperform the other three
it sucks you know and so I went to our
smart Master Pro and I said hey help me
run some scenarios out on this because
I'm about to change my advice after 30
years I mean after 25 years it's people
are going to be shocked they're going to
fall out in the floor Dave Ramsey
changed because he never changes you
know but I never change because I'm
right but if I'm wrong I need to change
so we dug it up dug into it and I had
him run a bunch of scenarios out and I
said okay what if if I'd didn't have for
the last 30 years if I didn't have
international in the mix if I just did
the other three run out what would have
happened and run it out what if it did
it was in there and uh certainly if you
run it out in um
like five year blocks or certainly the
last 10 years uh you would have over
performed not having it in there
so my advice you know but but the weird
thing is what he did do is he he pulled
up all of the
uh weird times in the economy we're kind
of in one of those right now as a matter
of fact like a bear market and we found
that the international shored up the
others uh because they would dive down
below it and then come back up past it
and the diversification actually did
work to where you ended up
mathematically better off because of
those weird anomaly downturns made up
the difference and uh we ran it out I
mean you can you can get with a good
investment broker like our smart
investor pros and they can run
hypotheticals they're called on the
computer and you can put like let's pick
four good mutual funds that are in the
four categories with long track records
and then let's run it with it run it
without it run it in you know for 15
years five years ten years 20 years 40
years let's run it back and forth back
and forth as best we can let's see what
would happen if we hadn't put it in
there have we been making a mistake all
this time which I because I was having
the exact same question you got Chris
it's a really good question is my point
I think but the weird thing was it it
worked out better to have it in there so
I kept it in there but it still kind of
baffles my mind a little bit because it
sucks so bad
is it I'm a great smart investor Pro
um can I give a shout out to him on the
air sure
he's Jake Buckwalter at my house
Whitaker everybody in four five six and
seven he's the call of this guy but he
showed me the international and it does
coincide with what you said I wanted to
ask on Eric because I thought everybody
should know and what your answer was but
there are a couple of years where it
just outperformed crazy and it made up
the difference do you think that might
happen again it does because it's
happening now maybe it happened at this
moment but Market cycle and so you're
going to have these weird anomaly years
in the rhythm of Market cycles of up and
down turns and yeah that so he found
what what I found when you all talked
about it right Chris that that right
that the math actually so it really what
it did is it was kind of a cool
illustration of the theory that
diversification is that you're safer
and you make more money in the long term
by having different kinds of things
rather than all your money in one thing
and that's really what it illustrates
and it's a beautiful question thanks for
the underhand pitch then Chris you
already knew the answer but yeah very
cool but we and all the other categories
did you guys run that like the
aggressive growth because they weren't
bothering me they were performing at or
above Market but the international is
just like it's just you know that makes
some bad metaphor but yeah it's it's
it'll get me in trouble but the um yeah
no it it's it's not it's not happy it's
not as happy a fund I mean and our
category uh but there's a weird thing
that some of these uh it's a foreign
market yeah stock that you're buying and
things are happening in those markets in
a Germany or uh that aren't happening
that aren't happening here at the same
time but with this downturn because it
feels more with inflation all of it it's
a it's a global yeah but a lot of it is
global sometimes you'll have a global
upheaval but yet the international
particular profitability of those
particular companies in that yeah does
isn't it has a it's not exactly inverse
to every negative thing right right but
it's enough that it it just proves up
our theory of diversification there you
go yeah so the Bible does say there is
you know one scripture that deals with
this but it doesn't point out the form
mutual funds it just says in
Ecclesiastes spread your portions to
seven yes to eight for disaster may come
upon the land and you can fill in the
blank on disaster whether it's covet or
planes flying into Towers or uh 2008
bubble bursts or the Great Depression or
whatever but if you have all your money
in one thing some duper drops the basket
on that thing then you're screwed yeah
and so the diversification is is just a
general biblical concept and you know we
knew in the investment World 30 years
ago when I started doing all this stuff
that that you don't put all your money
in one category because if you did you
would just pick aggressive growth
because it's always got the highest rate
of return right totally but it's got
exciting yeah yeah it's really exciting
but it's really exciting going down too
you know feeling it all yeah so you know
you don't take into consideration the
volatility and the offset and the other
stuff so it's a very interesting
question and uh I appreciate you
bringing it up also to tell folk so we
can say out loud that you know there are
things we don't change around here and
we're not going to change and I saw you
answer a thing on Instagram like you
just give your dad the same advice
because it's right you know it's we
don't you know you don't need to change
it but the uh except for the crap stable
that's fine except for the crab stable
and the Tesla but yeah but other than
that yeah
um
so there has to be some rebellion in the
middle child but the uh um the uh uh but
aside from that the the principles don't
change the processes in your life should
always change
the principle is you need to balance
your checkbook
even if there's an internet
that allows you to do all your Banking
online you still need to reconcile to
balance your checkbook or it may not be
a checkbook anymore
it is yes in the old days we got out and
you know they sent us all our checks
back in the mail we would mark them down
and then we would spend all this time
with a little 10 key calculator trying
to make sure we hadn't missed a check
and weren't out of reconciliation with
the bank weren't out of balance with uh
what we thought we had versus what we
really had and you still need to do that
stuff you still need to keep track of
your dad gum money uh that doesn't
change but how you do it yeah you still
need to be investing and diversifying
but how you do it could change but in
this case it worked out that it didn't
need to change this is the Ramsay show